[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alan shipnuck he's been busy here 25
years covering golf for sports
illustrated author of the phil mickelson
book the unauthorized phil mickelson
book available online wherever books are
sold and i noticed that alan there's a
picture where alan was going to the
press conference i believe and right
behind him is greg norman and he's being
escorted out and i said that fritzi
steve allen will join us here alan
uh did you have a credential for uh the
uh live tour
i did yes it was
kind of a cliffhanger i i had to send
three emails but they finally
credentialed me
yesterday morning so i
you know i was i was certainly entitled
to be at the press conference when they
when they gave me my credential
the very nice woman here uh running the
press room said you know phil
has asked or has made it clear that he
doesn't care to speak to you this week i
was like oh yeah it's not really up to
phil i mean
i
it's i'm here to do my job and not cater
to the whims of you know
pampered superstars so
uh i attended his press conference i was
just standing quietly in the back
listening
i had one boring golf question i was
thinking of asking but i was kind of
doing a vibe check and uh
see what the energy was like because
it's been a very weird awkward week in a
lot of a lot of different ways and um
but it just started when
when greg norman's goons descended on me
and
tossed me out so it was
this definitely uh you know i've been
thrown out of nicer places than this
insurance like that but
what did they tell you
what did they tell you when they
escorted you out
well they had like three different
stories none of them made sense
one of them was that i had the wrong
credential because they actually the
little piece of plastic they give you um
they run out of the ones that say media
on them so they gave me one that said
production but a lot of people have that
here because there's been more
press interest than expected so that
didn't make any sense um and then
then they said well i had that had to be
rescanned because every time you come
and go from the press area they scan you
but i was already within the boundary so
that made no sense
they were just they were just grasping
at straws i mean basically
you know norman wanted me ejected
because he was he was trying to do
phil's bidding and they were
you know these
these
necklace security guys who might not
have been you know
fully equipped for
the subtleties of the debate were just
coming up wherever they could to get me
out of there but the whole thing was
silly
did you so you just made eye contact
with phil but you didn't make any verbal
contact
i hadn't even really made eye contact
like he had just started he was i think
he was answering his first question i
mean it was like it had just begun
and um
so
you know
we really didn't i mean he
kind of had that thousand yard stare
going where he's kind of looking over
the heads of everybody so i'm not even
sure he saw me or knew what was going on
i thought nobody um misses the cut like
you're the first guy to miss the cut at
a live tournament
yeah indeed
i know there's been a lot of funny jokes
like um
uh you know my favorite is it usually
usually i'm gonna wait until the final
round to eject um
but
uh yeah there's there's been um
i mean the whole thing is just farcical
it's like
i'm just i'm just a lowly golf writer
this is just a meaningless golf
tournament on some level like what is
everyone so worried about these are not
state secrets
i mean i'm not out to get phil i have no
ill will towards him i just you know
he's the biggest news maker at what's
turned out to be a
uh you know a changing of the guard in
the professional game like it
for me to lob one softball out of this
is not gonna
have the earth stop spinning on its axis
like it's just a massive overreaction by
everyone involved uh before i let you go
we're talking alan chipnot 25 years on
the golf beat for sports illustrated
author of the phil mickelson book the
unauthorized biography take me back to
when phil talked about the saudis being
scary mfers
the was there any
on the record off the record or any
uh kind of mischaracterization there uh
of on phil's part of what was going to
be recorded by you
i mean that call was always on the
record phil knows that i know that for
him to say otherwise was was very
duplicitous and just not true and
you know it's of a piece of what what
just happened here this week it's like
um i guess we're learning that if you're
mixed up with the saudis you don't
support an independent free press like
uh that that sort of tracks here and
um you know these guys want the money
they don't want any accountability
and
uh it's it's just kind of it's absurd
the whole thing i mean
uh
for
you know normal kind of wants wants to
run the show like
this has been three decades in the
making for norman like he tried to get a
world tour going in in the early 90s
it's gonna be backed by rupert murdoch
and fox
he got out flanked by the pga tour and
they stole his idea and
he's been stewing ever since so this is
very personal for him
and he's trying to stage man's whole
thing in sort of an obsessive compulsive
way but you have to know there's going
to be some scrutiny and there's going to
be some
uh independent reporting and to try and
stifle that
it just tells you you know it's
revealing of who these people really are
and
so it's disappointing but i guess it's
not totally surprising yeah there's a
greater concern that it's a saudi-backed
golf league banishing journalists um not
a good look for them uh
are you still
they would understand that i mean the
lack of sophistication it's like
they've these guys have been taking
tough questions all week like
one one more golfy question is they're
not going to change the narrative of
this of this week but for them to strong
army out of the press conference and by
the way this is in front of all the
reporters i mean it was it was a cnn guy
who shot that video
and other people getting involved it's
just so dumb on their part more than
more than anything it's just
it's like
it's bad public relations for a a
circuit that desperately needs a
kind of an image makeover as it is
because
there are a lot of qualms about the
saudi involvement so you think they
would they'd be
playing extra nice but there's just a
total lack of sophistication here that
that incident revealed
all right well play nice over there alan
thanks for joining us
all right thanks for having me that's
alan shipnock the unauthorized biography
of phil mickelson